it has been more than a week since Jamie
Claus vanished and her parents were
found dead in Wisconsin but the Barron
County Sheriff is Chris Fitzgerald he
says he believes that Jamie is still
alive about 2,000 volunteers turned out
yesterday to search for clues Don Dahler
spoke to the sheriff about the
investigation
he's outside the Sheriff's Department in
Barren Wisconsin with more on this story
boy Don everybody hopes that little girl
is still okay good morning everybody
does good morning yes those volunteers
who are feeling the same way
touched for hours through really
difficult terrain yesterday
investigators are now assessing any
items they may have found and while they
say it's too early to know whether any
of those are connected to this case the
sheriff says he remains optimistic the
line of cars stretched for miles Tuesday
as people arrived to join the search for
clues in the disappearance of 13 year
old Jamie cloths the search took about
2,000 volunteers through thick brush and
woods wide open land and head-high
cornfields there's a little girl missing
the world most time you hear it on the
news and it's you know far away and kind
of disconnected but this is awfully
close to our community Butch Carter and
his wife Sarah drove around 50 miles to
be part of the search for them it's
personal and we have a teenage daughter
as well and my wife just keeps saying if
that was our daughter so here we are
Jamie hasn't been seen in more than a
week on October 15th a mostly inaudible
9-1-1 call was made from her mother's
cell phone minutes later when police
responded they found James and Denice
cloths dead in their home and their
daughter was gone the people in this
community have no reason to have lost
faith in what's going on here none none
at all
Barron County Sheriff Chris Fitzgerald
told us his team has been working around
the clock to find Jamie is there
something that you have that you can't
tell us but that makes you feel like
you're on the right Avenue no I thought
if we had a suspect I would put that out
to the public has the case gone cold no
it hasn't gone cold we're all
1,400 tips we continue to get tips in as
we speak it might take time but you're
optimistic we will bring Jaime home the
sheriff is going to hold a briefing
later today where he's expected to talk
about some of those items that were
found but as of yesterday none was
connected to this disappearance the
funerals for James and Denise cloths
Jamie's parents are this Saturday viana
we're thinking of everyone there in
Barron County that community really
coming together in this search Don thank
you